we have now to see how this process of
this pure notion of recognition in the
duplicating of self-consciousness in its
oneness appears - self-consciousness at
first it will exhibit the side of the
inequality of the two or the splitting
up of the middle term into the extremes
which as extremes are opposed to one
another one being only recognized the
other only recognizing
what we just developed in the last few
paragraphs was what we're referring to
now as this pure notion of recognition
the pure McGriff or concept of
recognition something that is not yet
entirely developed because remember
whenever we have something that's
immediate or or pure or anything like
that Hegel is just prepping us for a
dialectical ride ever gonna see a lot of
development taking place so in 185 the
question is that he's beginning with is
how does this this process appear to
self consciousness
what's our starting point we can AskMe
we just did this whole interesting
dialectical thing of the other was
related to me in the way that I'm
related to the other that's not how it
pans out at first though he says that it
takes place through a kind of inequality
this is an interesting stuff why can't
it just simply happen in terms of pure
reciprocity for Hegel here's one answer
to this for Hegel there is no provable
human state in which we were all equal
to each other and all recognizing each
other a wonderful original condition
from which there was some sort of fall
you know whether it was offending the
guns in some way or whether it was you
know the developments so technology
leading to self consciousness leading to
inequalities or any other sort of answer
like that he would reject anything along
those lines as we develop as human
beings out of our creme on creme
primeval condition or whatever it is
that that you know preceded human
awareness to you know determinately
human self-consciousness he thinks that
we emerge into a state of inequality in
which recognition is taking place but
it's a a one-sided recognition and he'll
talk here
about you know two extremes falling out
from this this middle term right he says
there's a splitting up of the middle
term into the extremes which is extremes
are opposed to each other that whole
mediation thing that we saw going on is
now no longer happening instead we have
one side that is recognizing and the
other side that is recognized one side
is acting we might say in the action is
that of recognition of the other but
it's not getting the same thing in
return so it's it's you know losing out
by the deal we might say if we think of
this in transactional terms and one of
the things that Hagel doesn't say in
this that we want to really keep in mind
is what I put here is a question mark
what is the action on the other extreme
on the one who is recognized how does it
come about that this one is doing the
work of recognizing and getting nothing
in return does that require some sort of
previous action on the part of this one
to you know benefit at the expense of
the other psychologically or in terms of
its importance or essentiality that's a
good thing to keep in mind as we move
forward
self-consciousness is to begin with
simple being for self self equal through
the exclusion from itself of everything
else for it its essence an absolute
object is I and in this immediacy or in
this mere being of its being for self it
is an individual what is other for it is
an essential negatively characterized
object but the other is also a
self-consciousness one individual is
confronted by another individual
appearing us immediately on the scene
they are for one another like ordinary
objects independent shapes individuals
submerged in the being or immediacy of
life for the object in its immediacy is
here determined as life they are for
each other shapes of consciousness which
have not yet accomplished the movement
of absolute abstraction of rooting out
all immediate being and of being merely
the purely negative being a self
identical consciousness in other words
they have not as yet exposed themselves
to each other in the form of pure being
for self or as self consciousnesses each
is indeed certain of its own self but
not of the other and therefore its own
self certainty still has no truth for it
would have truth only if its own being
for self had confronted it as an
independent object or what is the same
thing if the object had presented itself
as this pure self certainty but
according to the notion of recognition
this is possible only when each is for
the other what the other is for it only
when each is in its own self through its
own action and again through the action
of the other achieves this pure
abstraction of being for self
the key question in paragraph 186 then
is if we're starting to proceed with
this notion of recognition well why
doesn't self-consciousness have the
recognition of the other we saw that you
know there can be an inequality in which
there is a recognizing and are
recognized and each self-consciousness
can ask of itself why am I not getting
recognized by the other and in asking
that there's a kind of dynamic that is
going to play itself out leading
ultimately to what Hegel is going to
call the battle to the death and we're
not quite there yet what we want to see
is what steps we need to take to get
there another way of looking at this as
he talks about it there is why do we
have self-consciousness in a situation
and both of them are in this same
situation by the way I represented it in
a somewhat asymmetric way but both of
them are symmetrically in the same boat
why is it that self-consciousness can be
certain of itself but that self
certainty doesn't possess truth so
here's another key idea that's being
developed here he says self
consciousness has these different
characters or you know it's got these
features to it it is to begin with
simple beating for self alright it knows
what it is or at least it thinks it
knows what it is it has some sort of
reflexive relation to itself self equal
through the exclusion from itself of
everything else so it excludes
everything else that is what allows it
to have a self equality that is self
certainty right it's good say I know
what I am because I'm not that over
there I'm not any of that stuff I'm not
the things that I'm eating I'm not the
things that I wear and not my relations
with other people I am I I am me and
everything else is what it is so it says
for it it's essence an absolute object
is i right put here you know it's
essence is to be an I to say I am the
one who exists I am the one who matters
I am the one whose perspective has to be
taken into
for myself at the same time the other
self-consciousness can of course do the
same thing and is in fact doing the same
thing with itself so it's he goes on and
he says in this immediacy right
immediacy always a bad thing from a
Hegelian perspective or not necessarily
a bad thing it's the first stage in the
development it's not the whole story in
this immediacy or in this mere being of
its being for a self it is also an
individual this is important to be an
individual particularly for thinking
about things in a Hegelian way where
you've got like a whole universe of
connected things that not only you know
are at this particular place and time
but stretch throughout human history
backwards and forwards to be an
individual to some degree means to cut
yourself off you know Hegel was somebody
who liked Spinoza's notion that every
determination is in some respect
a negation a pushing aside a pushing out
of one's perspective that of others so
he goes on and he says what is other for
it is an unofficial negatively
characterized object this is the first
way in which it relates itself to the
other you know it can it can be an
individual by not being the other things
which don't really matter mattering
importance essentiality is on this side
doesn't go on for very long though right
as we've seen he says but the other is
also self-consciousness the other is
another individual an individual
confronted by another individual now we
have a relation between the two and both
of them can ask hey why aren't you
recognizing me I'll recognize you after
you recognize me I want some recognition
from you even already contained in that
is the notion that the other is of being
capable of providing to oneself what it
is that one is capable of providing to
them so that's very important he says
appearing thus immediately on the scene
they are for each other like ordinary
objects independent shapes they are in
relation to each other as objects as the
what he calls independent shapes here as
something that is possessed of
subjectivity is possessed of importance
on its side but not completely right not
as much as me over here on this side
there's another problem too they are
both as Hegel says immersed or submerged
in the being or immediacy of life that
is they have determinacy they have not
yet gone through a very important
harrowing process he says the object in
its immediacy is here determined as life
I am related as a desiring being to
another living being we've seen this
already play itself out in the earlier
paragraphs of self-consciousness
chemically so we're we're sort of
bringing ourselves back up to date at
this point Anna he was a how did he says
they are for each other shapes of
consciousness which have not yet
accomplished an important movement the
movement of absolute abstraction of
routing out of all immediate being that
a being merely the purely negative being
of self identical consciousness so they
haven't removed himself from the
immediacy of life yet neither neither
one neither side of this has done that
he goes on and he says in other words
they have not yet as yet exposed
themselves to each other in the form of
pure being for self or self
consciousness what does this mean they
have exposed themselves to each other or
they have run across each other they
have encountered each other as living
things as simple beings for self but not
yet as beings for self that have
developed to a certain extent that have
gone through an important experience he
says they have not yet become aware of
that
there as self-consciousness as in their
full extent
he says II Beach is indeed certain of
its own self right there's this this
relation of saying I am I know who I am
I don't know who the hell you are I owe
you to understand what Who I am I I
don't get you so I'll push you over
there and the other guys doing the same
thing at the same time or it could be
you know a man and a woman it could be
two friends it could be whoever right in
these encounters he goes on and he says
each is indeed certain of its own self
but not certain of the other each does
not have a grasp of what it is that the
other is other than it being another
individual and other self-consciousness
but what does that mean to be another me
are they exactly like me clearly not so
what do these differences matter are
they a threat to me I don't know are
they going to affirm me I'm not sure we
can go on and on and on with different
modalities of this so he says therefore
because they're not certain of the other
its own certainty lacks truth remember
how this play of certainty and truth
that has gone on throughout this entire
dialectic you know you often get one and
then lose hold on the other we want to
have both at the same time we want to
have self certainty that is at the same
time they develop self certainty not an
immediate one so it also possesses truth
there you might say this is self
certainty or certainly taken to a higher
degree when you have the the certainty
of certainty you actually have truth but
you only have that through a process of
assuring one song and in this case the
process is going to be recognition not
just an epistemological process but an
interpersonal process this isn't
something that one could do I'll add a
cart and a stove heated room all by
oneself this is something that has to be
carried out with determinate human
beings engaging with each other so it
makes
much more difficult to pull off so he
goes on me says it would have its truth
only if its own being for self can't
confronted it as an independent object
if it's being for self is over here on
the side of the other then it can
actually make that into an independent
object that it can try to grapple with
notice that this requires a sort of loss
of being for self that we saw happen
earlier that's what makes the other kind
of scary kind of threatening kind of
anxiety provoking you know I lose my
essentiality into the whatever it is on
the other I don't know what they're
gonna do with it I don't know if they're
gonna take good care of it if they're
gonna turn it against me I have to take
a risk in order for that to happen so he
says it would have its truth only if its
own being for self Kant confronted it as
an independent object or what is the
same thing if the object had presented
itself as this pure self certainty the
other gets to be self certainty and then
as I confront that I can take stock of
what my own self certainty means so he
goes on he says according to the notion
of recognition this is possible only
when each is for the other one the other
is for only when there is a kind of
reciprocity only when in saying i i am
also at the same time gesturing towards
the you and vice versa
now this is possible to you know take
place not only in positive ways where
we're all you know one big happy family
on the same page with each other
everything is blissful but much more
often in terms of negative relations
with the other as well so it says only
when each is for the other with the
others for it only when each is in its
own self through its own action and
again through the action of the other
achieves this pure abstraction of being
for some only when that occurs this
abstraction of being for self occurs
this externalization this sacrifice of
it only when that occurs is recognition
in its full sense going to be possible
the presentation of itself however is
the pure abstraction of
self-consciousness consists in showing
itself as the pure negation of its
objective mode or in showing that it is
not attached to any specific existence
not to the individuality common to
existence as such that it is not
attached to life this presentation is a
two-fold action action on the part of
the other and action on its own part
insofar as it is the action of the other
each seeks the death of the other
but in doing so the second kind of
action action on its own part is also
involved for the former involves the
staking of its own life thus the
relation of the two self conscious
individuals is such that they prove
themselves and each other through a
life-and-death struggle they must engage
in this struggle for they must raise
their certainty of being for themselves
to truth both in the case of the other
and in their own case and it is only
through staking one's life that freedom
is one only thus is it proved that for
self consciousness it's essential being
is not just being not the immediate form
in which it appears not at submergence
in the expanse of life but rather that
there is nothing present in it which
could not be regarded as a vanishing
moment that it is only pure being for
self the individual who has not risked
his life may well be recognized as a
person but he has not attained to the
truth of this recognition as an
independent self-consciousness similarly
just as each stakes his own life so each
must seek the others death before it
values the other know more than itself
it's essential being as present to
itself in the form of another it is
outside of itself and must rid itself of
its self externality the other is an
immediate consciousness entangled in a
variety of relationships and it must
regard its other nassif or self or as an
absolute negation
in paragraph 187 we now come to one of
Hegel's most famous moments of the
phenomenology of spirit that is the
struggle or battle to the death that
takes place between the two reciprocally
related self-consciousness is the
confrontation of self with the other in
the most naked way and I actually took a
phrase that occurs a little bit later on
in the paragraph as a somewhat
tongue-in-cheek way of talking about
this you know the struggle to the death
or and if we think about like you know
how to win friends and influence people
that are you know on any of these sort
of things how to raise oneself certainty
to truth this is what you need to go
through if you want to engage in the
kind of psychological self-help that's
required to truly become an individual
here we actually sound a little bit more
like you know cheap versions of
Nietzsche rather than eagle but that's
really what's going on in this in this
in this passage you know it hasn't
occurred to me as I'm reading through it
another meme that's been circulating
around quite a bit also fits into this
quite well as a question that the reader
might be asking at that at this point
and that's the boy that escalated quick
meme right when you see somebody who has
a little tiff and suddenly they're
burning the office down or you know any
other sort of very over-the-top reaction
why do the two self-consciousness is you
have to try to kill each other isn't
that a strange waiting for things to you
know proceed you know we have one
self-consciousness coming along over
here and it runs into another
self-consciousness over here and there's
this interplay of recognizing that
there's something similar to one's self
in the other and now suddenly they're
gonna kill each other why does it have
to go that way well Hegel does see and
inherent necessity involved in this and
it's not just that as human beings were
driven by homicidal impulses or we're
all sadist deep down inside no and it
really has to do with this this what we
might call at least at
first tragic structure of recognition
that's going on that's going to get
mediated later on into something much
better but at first has to involve this
throwing oneself into the balance so
let's see how this proceeds he says the
presentation of itself as the pure
abstraction of self-consciousness
consists in showing itself as the pure
negation of its objective mode great so
now it actually starts to sound as if
maybe self consciousnesses are going to
try to kill each other which is a very
determinate very visceral act because
they're doing metaphysics well you know
yes that's true but it's metaphysics um
on the nature of the person he says this
he calls as a pure negation of their
objective mode why does that matter well
you know they're trying to come to an
understanding of what indeed they are
each one what am i what am i and they're
they're trying to make sense of this by
getting away from any sort of specific
existence by getting away from any
attachment to the realm of what Hegel
was calling life
the merely living the determinate in in
that respect so he says you know this is
showing itself as the pure negation of
its objective but what I can see myself
as what I would I take myself to be at
first not or Orin is showing it's not
attached to any specific existence not
to the individuality common to existence
as such not to just being this person
here then it's not attached to life so
he says this presentation is a two-fold
action and I've drawn this in this way
on the board or rather schematically
depicted it to show the reciprocity
that's involved here
each self-consciousness as hiegel says
seeks the death of the other we'll see
why it does so in a moment but even more
important what it's doing in the process
is risk
getting its own life its throwing its
own life its own specific existence its
own here and now its own possibility of
being something essential being
something individual into the balance
its throwing it at risk it's making
itself vulnerable to other forces it's
not just closing itself up inside of
itself it's taking the ultimate chance
the only reason why the other can
actually seek the death of the self is
because the self is risking its life in
the process if it wanted to be totally
secure in wall itself off the other
couldn't seek its death but by going out
to try to also seek the death of the
other
it puts itself at risk and you know
think about it in a number of different
ways you can't attack a person without
becoming vulnerable yourself you know if
we think about in terms of classical
fencing right I actually when we go off
screen for just a moment now this is not
a sword but this is a stick you know
from Lacan which is a a martial art that
was developed originally in France by
people who didn't have swords but it
uses some of the same moves as fencing
does because fencing is divided up into
all these different quarters right so
two different ways to protect your head
right both of them open you up to other
things
any particular attack that you would
make right would open you up to other
counter-attacks and so on to be on the
offense means that you abandon certain
defenses at the same time to take a
defensive stance loses you the
initiative required in this case to get
you what it is that you want there's a
lot more that could be said about that a
lot of other examples that could be
adduced but I think you get the basic
idea so he says this presentation is a
two-fold action right there's a two-fold
action going on here insofar as it is
the action of the other each is seeking
the death of the other each one is
after the other and trying to subject it
to becoming on essential to becoming a
nullity each is trying to treat the
other as something that can be consumed
he says but in doing so the second kind
of action action on its own part is also
involved what does this involved
stinking its own life putting its own
life into the balance so he says thus
the relation of the two self conscious
individuals is such that they prove
themselves and each other through a
life-and-death struggle there's you know
I don't want to try to romanticize this
into you know like samurais fighting
each other or you know the individuals
who get to know each other through
sparring and beating the crap out of
each other I don't want to try to you
know make that anything anything other
than what it is
however Hegel is saying something here
that even when we strip away all the
romanticizing varnish that's put onto it
usually by people at a great distance
behind it from that sort of thing and we
think about people who genuinely do
engage each other in conflict and
conflict where there are stakes that
matter not necessarily by the way one's
own life but perhaps one's livelihood
perhaps one's reputation all these sorts
of things that we tend to identify with
oneself that we can throw into the
balance the love of the other even
perhaps right the respect of the other
there is something that's gained thereby
and it's not only gained for oneself but
also something that is thereby being
given to the other and the other is
engaged in this process of gaining and
giving at the same time as well that's
how Hegel sees this so if we go on
he says they must engage in this
struggle for they must raise their
certainty of being for themselves to
truth we saw again that each side can
can have a self certainty but it's not
an assured self certainty unless it also
encompasses and involves the other so by
risking itself it can get to know what
it truly is through the other who's
doing the same thing at the same time
also trying to attain the truth of
itself certainty both of them are doing
that both of them are engaged in the
same process but they're doing it in a
way that's hostile to each other so he
says here's where it gets you know a
little bit more controversial something
that we're going to have to take up at
multiple points through this it is only
through stinking one's own life that
freedom is one only thus is it proved
that for self consciousness it's
essential being is not just being not
the immediate form in which it appears
not at submergence in the expanse of
life but rather that there is nothing
present in it which could not be
regarded as a vanishing moment that it
is only pure being for some does this
mean that unless we actually like you
know risking our lives that every
moments not just risking our lives - by
the way by braving the environment or
dealing with technological issues but
you know directly engaging at other
human being and because we choose to not
because some government sends us off to
war or you know otherwise coerces us if
we're not doing that do we not really
have freedom I don't think that Hegel is
actually saying that but what he is
saying is that something essential to
freedom is being expressed in this
dynamic that unless there is something
at risk you don't really have genuine
freedom why not it has to do with what
self consciousness is aware of you know
and we could say much more about this
but I don't want to get I don't wanna
get bogged down at this point because
we're gonna get a lot of that as we go
into the sections on spirit in
particular so he says the individual who
is not risked his life may well be
recognized as a person may well be
grasped as a self-consciousness but he
has not attained to the truth of this
recognition as an independent self
consciousness so personhood is something
that can be bestowed upon
people but unless they go through some
sort of experience in which something
like this is occurring Hegel is saying
they don't yet have the truth of that
personhood they don't yet have the truth
of that self-consciousness because they
haven't realized just how contingent
everything is just how what seems
totally essential to us could be taken
away at any moment or it could be thrown
away by us of our own accord this is a
very deep insight that he that he's
having here so he goes on and he says
similarly just as each states it's his
own life each must also seek the others
death now why that's the question here
why does it why does it escalate to
wanting to kill the other person to not
only desiring recognition from them to
not only desiring them in whatever sense
we do desire them but desiring the death
the the annihilation of the other and
and we also have the other doing that in
relation to us and a certain respect
we're desiring the other to try to want
to kill us too well why why is it well
we can't risk it here's here's one easy
answer
can't really risk our own life if the
other person isn't gonna cooperate and
try to kill us right it's not much of a
game if it is indeed a game you know
this tunnel to the death it's not much
of a game if you're you know think about
in terms of first-person shooter games
right something that I think many people
are quite familiar with it's not much of
a game if you play on some sort of god
mode where nobody can actually touch you
you're just shooting everybody you're
killing everybody it gets very boring
very quickly doesn't it we need some
sort of challenge there's nothing at
risk if the other one isn't actually a
danger to us we might think about this
in all sorts of other modes as well
financial loss and risk right what goes
on in infatuation and relationships and
taking a chance you know the other
person could turn you down
just destroy you right there's no
risking without that but there's an even
more important point here when I have
treated myself through seeking the death
of the other and risking my life when I
have treated myself as something that
can strip away this objective mode of my
being that can strip away the immediacy
of my being the immersion in life the
specific existence that I have when I
say like you know very metaphorically I
say all right I'm going to take off the
jacket and I'm going to fight you if I'm
willing to take away not only the jacket
but the tie and you know the chance that
my glasses are gonna get smashed up and
that I might might end up in the
hospital or might end up on the floor
getting kicked until I'm dead if I'm
willing to do that sort of thing and
treat myself as if I'm something that
can be thrown into the balance I'm also
looking at the other as the same kind of
being that is likewise able to do that
to seek their death in a certain way is
to treat them as if they're truly a
human being that sounds completely
paradoxical doesn't it but at this stage
of the dynamic that's part of what's
involved in this dialectic of
recognition thank God we're going to get
past that relatively quickly and it's
not all going to be about us you know
going around and trying to kill each
other
but that's what is happening at this
stage so he says just as each stakes its
own life each must seek the others death
for it values the other know more than
itself if I if I treat myself as
something that can be thrown into the
balance that I could risk complete
annihilation I also have to treat the
other in the same way it's essential
being is present to it in the form of
another it is outside of itself and must
itself of its self externality that
others challenging me over there by
being the same kind of being as I am by
taking the chance of getting killed
itself he says the other is an immediate
consciousness entangled in a variety of
relationships and it must regard its
other Ness as a pure being for self or
as an absolute negation so what is the
other Nisour the other so that's why
that guy over there is going to try to
kill me to both so both of these self
consciousnesses are attempting to raise
their own self certainty to truth and
they're doing it in this twofold way
they do that by displaying themselves as
pure being for self to themselves but
also to the other that's what's going on
in the struggle to death that's why
things escalated so quickly
you